a escasas horas de que concluya el
título 42 la situación en la frontera
por lo menos entre Tijuana y San Diego
sigue siendo hasta ahora de cierta calma
continúan sin embargo varados por
decirlo de alguna manera entre ambos
muros fronterizos que dividen Tijuana
México y San Diego California entre 300
y 400 migrantes se dice que
principalmente varones obviamente hay
mujeres se habla de que podría haber
también algunos o varios muchos porque
no menores que están soportando
condiciones difíciles de clima también
sobre todo calor en el día en las noches
baja la temperatura lluvia y Bueno sobre
todo gente de Centroamérica de
Sudamérica pero también de otros países
que están también a la expectativa sin
saber qué va a ocurrir el día de mañana
cuando se levanten el título cuarenta y
dos mientras tanto bueno muchas personas
continúan aquí acercándose a entregarles
algo de comida alimentos bolsas de
basura que ellos están improvisando para
cubrirse justamente del tiempo que están
utilizando como tiendas de campaña Por
decirlo de alguna manera agua incluso
algunos activistas que también se han
ofrecido a llevarse sus teléfonos
celulares y recargarlos para que ellos
puedan seguir comunicándose y pidiendo
también a través de las distintas
aplicaciones alimento que los mismos
repartidores de comida se acercan aquí y
les entre